[Musique]
photo tu commençais à 14 ans et demi je
fais une comédie dans laquelle il y
avait une femme de 45 ans qu'à cette
aune là je croyais que c'était une
vieille affreuse qu'une par hugues blanc
et tout le monde disait que c'était cas
curieux que je savais sept
petits-enfants il avait joué très bien
et est alors je voulais aller à
l'académie d'art dramatique faire très
sérieusement très très sévères d'amour
les études et les parents comme toujours
hainaut c'est une honte une honte la
poussière de stages ou bien des parcours
chez nico ticot rodez à nîmes accord
pour le disait toujours ma mère alors
lisez notre tu peux pas être tu ne dois
pas la famille tous à une vie normale
bourgeois normale et non pour moi
c'était absolument impossible décidé
d'aller khademi trois ans d'académie
très
très sérieusement
et là au début de vue ne pensiez côté a
d'une part c'est pas du cinéma jamais
même physiquement c'était pas facile
parce que la beauté italienne s'était
gina lollobrigida avec una vita comme ça
après c'est la bellissime cet open
sophia loren c'était pas moi moi j'ai
fais
pas comme maintenant 13 et je m'habiller
façon
très normal
j'étais mal je n'avais pas le visage
pour pour tous par le cnra et on a
essayé mais calogero antonioni qui vous
est découverte oui parce que
moi j'ai doublé les actrices italienne
alitalia moi j'étais la seule actrice
qui venait du théâtre pouffe jouer avec
sa voix qui étaient respectés et
antonioni il devrait doubler une actrice
italienne il est venu au
4éme hdidou il m'a vu dinh hook vous
savez il ya le losc m moi j'étais comme
ça a doublé il était derrière et il m'a
dit les yards la belle a donc fait
d'études
j'étais tellement avec ma nuque c'est
dommage et
on a commencé à
être des amis van moer des amis
appellent à s'aimer et pour l' aventure
folle avant tout à mon premier film qui
a gagné
25 prix d'allemands d'un pied en
amérique
partout on était désigné comme tout le
monde celle et
les producteurs on était isolé dans une
île de l'éolien fond de la sicile et
après un mois on est isolé parce qu'on
n'avait pas d'âme à manger rien même pas
des communications mais pas d'argent a
besoin de payer et
et quand il est arrivé quelqu'un de rome
pour nous dire comme ait été le les
roches il demandait alors le film ça va
ça marche
pour le ter indiqué le film machemehl
c'est un désastre elle elle est très
bonne actrice le nez
elle n'est pas belle elle peut pas faire
un film
vous devez recommencer une mois de
travail devra composer avec une autre
n'importe qui mais une très belle viande
mais quel âge il a dit qu'on voit on
continue comme ça qu'elle est ce que
vous avez quelques faiblesses que vous
avez milité dans les mouvements
féministes vous avez donné votre nom
pour cautionner des causes non parce que
je ne veux pas je n'ai pas le courage
d'aller d'allah de faire des je crois
qu'il faut vivre dans certaine manière
être certaine manière et avec ça on peut
aider également en f1
sans le savoir je suis devenu un symbole
pour les frères italiens comme rencontre
dans la rue m'embrasse ma disant oh tu
dis qu'à comme je voudrais être tué
ça me donne même un peu la base parce
que je sais pas comment les régler tout
ça mais je crois un moment pour pour la
façon de travailler
et de vivre
[Musique]